[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal préparé par les
équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 25
novembre voici les titres de cette
édition
le sky business dès la convention
d'affaires de saint quentin en yvelines
a eu lieu aujourd'hui une sixième
édition 100% en ligne cette année
objectif développer l'attractivité du
territoire au programme 400 entreprises
et 1200 rendez vous c'est la journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes avec la
crise sanitaire les signalements ont
augmenté les violences intrafamiliales
était en hausse de 40% après le premier
confinement focus sur les dispositifs
existants
et puis des artistes des assises de la
réussite scolaire ont pris place à
saint-ouen en seine-saint-denis
un événement organisé par la région ile
de france au programme ateliers des
changes pour lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire
et avant de développer ses titres
olivier verront ministre des solidarités
de la santé et jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale et se
sont exprimés ce jeudi 25 novembre une
conférence de presse dans le cadre de la
lutte contre l'épidémie de covile 19
plus de trente deux mille nouveaux cas
ont été recensés ces dernières 24 heures
pour l'instant pas de confinement ou de
couvre-feu à prévoir mais plusieurs
mesures annoncées notamment à partir du
15 janvier le pass sanitaire sera
conditionnée pour tous à une dose de
rappel du vaccin un rappel à effectuer
entre cinq et sept mois après la
dernière injection sous peine de voir
son passé ni terre désactivé et puis les
tests pcr permettant de bénéficier du
passé ni terre pendant 72 heures
passeront à 24 heures autre mesure le
port du masque est obligatoire dans tous
les lieux fermés mais aussi dans les
lieux spécifiques en extérieur comme les
marchés par exemple et puis enfin côté
éducation 6,8 1500 classes de primaire
ont fermé en france les classes ne
fermeront plus automatiquement au
premier cas de kovy de recenser
l'ensemble de la classe sera à tester
les élèves avec un test non pourrons
alors retourner en cours
[Musique]
et le ska e-business décès la convention
d'affaires de saint quentin en yvelines
elle a lieu aujourd'hui une sixième
édition 100% en ligne cette année pour
la deuxième fois consécutive avec la
crise sanitaire l'objectif développer
l'attractivité du territoire c'était
donc ce jeudi 25 novembre 400
entreprises 1200 en rendez vous
d'affaires alexandre allard rosetti vous
êtes avec nous bon soir bonsoir donc
vous êtes chargé vice présidente chargée
du développement économique et à
l'attractivité du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines merci d'être avec
nous on le sait donc l'objectif du sky
business des essais et la mise en
relation entre les entreprises du
territoire quel bilan déjà vous faites
de cette sixième édition
alors on est très content du bilan
puisque c'est là donc la deuxième année
vous l'avais dit en distance yale et
pour autant on a une hausse
d'inscriptions de près de 20% le nombre
d'entreprises donc en tout on a eu 4 438
entreprises
650 participants et surtout
3200 mise en relation
programme est planifiée donc c'est
vraiment un très bon résultat et puis je
crois que le retour des entreprises en
fin d'après midi était vraiment un taux
de satisfaction de 90 % donc je crois
que ça a été une belle réussite
vous venez de nous donner ces chiffres
du coup est ce que ça veut dire que cet
événement fonctionne toujours aussi bien
malgré que ce soit en ligne et plus au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
oui alors ça fonctionne forcément un
petit peu mieux quand c'est en
présentiel mais c'est vrai qu'on avait
testé ce format l'année dernière à cause
de la crise il a vu les incertitudes on
en avait reconduit et on se rend compte
que ça fonctionne quand même toujours
très bien ça veut dire que les
entreprises ont une réelle appétence
pour justement avoir des rendez-vous de
business de décupler leurs opportunités
d'affaires ça leur permet également
d'enrichir le réseau puisque en fait on
est quand même un territoire il ya dix
sept mille établissements et on s'est
aussi rendu compte que les entreprises
avaient parfois chercher un peu loin des
compétences ou des affaires alors qu'ils
ont des choses qui sont sur le
territoire donc je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne et qui
continuera à fonctionner vous venez de
le dire le territoire compte donc dix
sept mille entreprises de tous types des
grands groupes des pme des start-up
comment elles font pour collaborer
malgré finalement leur différence de
taille et quel est l'intérêt de ces
collaborations
alors justement c'est au travers de ce
que nous pouvons mettre en place pour le
faire en sorte qu'ils se rencontrent
qu'on arrive à développer des
coopérations et surtout à développer des
réseaux parce que ça je pense que c'est
vraiment très important donc
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à des actions
assez variés sur ce sujet et donc
continue bien sûr allez développer on a
une maison de l'entreprise qui s'appelle
husky cube nous avons un incubateur avec
des start up mais qui reçoit également
des entreprises dans le cadre de
formation par exemple et donc tout ça
fait que ça peut ça permet de créer du
réseau et de l'interaction entre nous
entre nos entreprises
une question peut être un petit peu plus
globale en quoi la relance économique a
permis de faciliter cette mise en
relation avec les entreprises
alors ça nous a permis lui puisqu'il ya
eu d un plan de relance qui a été initié
par la région et par l'état auxquels on
a on a participé au travers d'un fonds
qui s'appelle le fond résilience et le
service dédié au développement
économique a passé beaucoup d'appels par
exemple à destination des entreprises
pour leur faire connaître les
dispositifs de relance je pense que ça
contribue forcément à renforcer notre
foi notre la connaissance que des
entreprises peuvent avoir de 50 ans ni
dîner de ce que cette coeur de
l'opération peut leur apporter
vous sentez en tout cas vous avez
l'impression que le business a repris
justement sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines et dans les yvelines
plus largement
alors oui je pense que c'est je pense
que factuellement c'est en train de 7 en
train de reprendre et en tout cas on
sent une vraie volonté les entreprises
de continuer à
produire aussi des emplois
et puis à investir dans différents
domaines vous avais parlé il ya 56 grand
compte déjà sur saint quentin
donc oui je pense qu'effectivement tout
ça contribue à les aider à les porter
dans leurs investissements et alors j'ai
pas de chiffre à ce jour mais je crois
qu'on peut constater que les plans de
relance en tout cas ont eu des effets
positifs
merci beaucoup alexandra rosetti d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir je le rappelle
vous êtes donc la vice présidente
chargée du développement économique et à
l'attractivité du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines merci
[Musique]
je vous le disais en titre tout à
l'heure les confinements successifs ont
été la source d'une force augmentation
de signalements de violences conjugales
focus sur les différents dispositifs
existants dont les yvelines avec céline
charles et xavier gélin
[Musique]
à
nous tout c'est un collectif qui lutte
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
les militants dans chaque ville vont
mettre en place des actions de type
distribution upholland tôt m ou des
départs groupés pour la marche quand on
fait à chaque mois deux mois chaque mois
de novembre
[Musique]
on entend beaucoup dire mais c'est bon
en france
il ya plus de problème de ce type il ya
des pays où c'est beaucoup plus grave et
cetera mais quand on regarde les
chiffres
au final ils sont importants voilà on a
quand même encore 102 féminicide là
cette année pour l'instant les gens
n'ont pas conscience en fait de
l'importance de ces violences là encore
en france donc c'est important voilà de
faire prendre conscience de ça et que du
coup derrière ça
incite à ce que soient mises en place
des politiques publiques et qui est des
budgets nécessaires qu'ils soient mises
en place pour pour régler ces problèmes
[Musique]
via un numéro qui est joignable 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 c'est le 39
19 donc ça c'est valable aussi bien pour
les personnes qui sont victimes que pour
les personnes qui peuvent être dans le
voisinage qui entendent eux
des personnes proches en fait qui
veulent savoir quoi faire pour pour
aider dans ces cas là par contre si la
personne est vraiment en situation de
danger imminent c'est le 17 qu'il faut
appeler ainsi la police et puis sinon il
ya le numéro 0 800 05 95 95 ces viols
femmes informations
et on reste sur le même thème car à
l'occasion de la journée de lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
l'association social sport et
performance de mantes-la-jolie a diffusé
un documentaire sur leur projet pédales
contre les violences conjugales il
raconte les aventures de 12 jeunes qui
ont traversé la france à vélo pour une
cause les violences conjugales le
reportage de ces diaga tsongo et maxime
l'aï regardé
une rencontre entre des jeunes est une
cause coups de pédales contre les
violences conjugales est un projet mené
par l'association nantaise social sport
et performance il ya quelques mois c'est
jane ont pris la route à vélo direction
montpellier en soutien aux femmes
victimes de violences pour cette journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes un
documentaire retraçant le parcours de
ces jeunes mais aussi des témoignages a
été diffusé au centre culturel le
chaplin de mantes-la-jolie ont traversé
cette étape cette ville plus de 790 km
après les films documentaires de base
c'était surtout pour c'était surtout
pour nous et de fil en aiguille on s'est
rendu compte que ça pourrait en être un
outil pédagogique super intéressant un
périple à vélo parfois compliqué à
réaliser mais avec un objectif en tête
pour les jeunes lutter contre les
violences conjugales sympathique nous
entendrons fait qu'on soit petit ou
grand dans le futur et voilà c'est
important de 6 sensibiliser
personnellement déjà pour éviter que ça
puisse arriver au sein de notre propre
foyer plus de 1600 euros ont été
récoltés grâce à une cagnotte litchi
pour le centre d'information sur les
droits des femmes et des familles des
yvelines cette journée a été co piloté
par la ville et le commissariat de
mantes la jolie on a mobilisé les
acteurs qu'on connaît les partenaires de
terrain cet après midi c'est les
partenaires essentiellement le qui je
travaille au quotidien au commissaire à
la clinique viennent s'exprimer la
diffusion du documentaire a été suivie
de tables rondes des intervenants et des
professionnels de terrain qui jalonnent
le parcours d'une victime on va
présenter en fait tous les maillons de
la chaîne puis du début quand on parle à
son ami bah voila mon mari m'a frappé
j'ai un problème et puis en fait comment
faire les initiations aux gestes de
défense et des débats autour de cette
problématique
sont prévus jusqu'au 2 décembre quand la
jolie
[Musique]
c'est un tout autre sujet à présent la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines connaît depuis ce
mercredi 24 novembre son nouveau
président il s'agit de guillaume cairou
il a été élu à l'unanimité des 30
membres de la nouvelle assemblée de cci
78 il succède à gérard bacheliers à la
tête de l'institution depuis huit ans
maintenant l'entrepreneur originaire de
mantes la jolie dirigé la société
didaxis spécialisé dans le conseil aux
personnes qui souhaitent entreprendre
tout en étant salarié ces priorités
seront d'accompagner les entrepreneurs
d'investir dans les filières d'avenir ou
encore à d'intensifier les formations
pour les demandeurs d'emploi dans les
secteurs en tension sur l'emploi
justement
guillaume cairou sera d'ailleurs
l'invité du 78 week-end ce vendredi 26
novembre ce sera à 18h en éducation à
présent bien que les yvelines soit l'un
des plus épargné l'un des départements
les plus épargnées par le décrochage
scolaire en ile-de-france certaines
zones sensibles persiste dans le
département pour lutter contre ce fléau
présent dans l'ensemble de la région une
journée spéciale était consacrée au
siège de la région ile-de-france à
saint-ouen dans le 93 au programme est
bien des ateliers de prise de parole par
des participants de divers milieux le
but trouver les meilleures solutions
pour les années à venir bixente imerys
entité ban estime charles bonjour
aujourd'hui tv 60,18 vous emmène au
siège de la région ile de france pour
les assises de la réussite scolaire une
journée entièrement consacrée à la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire va
commencer juste derrière moi par une
conférence pilotée par james chéron
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france déléguée aux lycées c'est
parti
pour commencer ce tour d'horizon des
assises de la réussite scolaire de sun
avec james chéron vice président de la
région ile de france chargée des lycées
bonjour bonjour donc monsieur chéron
comment se passe cette journée qu'est ce
qui va se passer aujourd'hui
concrètement c'est une journée de
travail qui permet de rassembler tous
les acteurs qui conjuguent leurs efforts
pour lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire nous avons une convention qui a
été signée en 2018 redoublent en 2020 il
s'agit d'évaluer les termes de cette
convention de regarder comment nous
pouvons aller plus loin donc ça a
commencé par une conférence de
présentation ce matin est là toute la
journée des ateliers qui vont se suivre
quelle sont les objectifs alors il ya
des ateliers qui se tiennent au siège du
conseil régional ici à saint-ouen et
puis dans quasiment une trentaine
d'établissements répartis dans
l'ensemble de la région ile de france
pour que les acteurs aux locales les
enseignants les élèves c'est important
que les élèves y travaillent puissent
effectivement sur des thématiques
particulières échanger construire et
puis lorraine synthèse en fin de journée
[Musique]
nous sommes avec christoph keller au
recteur de paris et de la région
ile-de-france bonjour bonjour monsieur
concrètement qu'est ce que ça représente
le décrochage scolaire dans la région
ile de france il s'agit de 25000 jeunes
qui sont identifiés comme décrocheurs
dans les faits il y en a 50 % qui sont
véritablement décrocheurs et sur 50% il
y en a un tiers qu'on a qu'on n'arrive
pas à joindre malgré l'ensemble des
dispositifs qui sont mobilisés une
journée comme celle ci est évidemment
extrêmement importante parce que d'abord
nous sortons d'une période où les gens
ne se voyait pas et rien ne vaut la
présence physique pour se parler pour
resserrer les liens on va justement allé
constater ça sur les ateliers présents
aujourd'hui merci monsieur guerrero
d'après sayabou
[Musique]
nous sommes avec raphaël lartigau
conseillère de l'actrice versailles d'un
où se tient et se tiennent des ateliers
en ce moment même qu'est-ce qui vous
avez retiré de cette matinée france un
travail vraiment de mutualisation de
bonnes pratiques pour aider nos jeunes
élèves en rupture scolaire
les aider à trouver une voie à
raccrocher à finalement se projeter dans
un avenir donc vous vous êtes animatrice
pour ses ateliers quel est votre rôle
c'est d'orienter la parole les sujets
c'est non seulement d'orienter la parole
mais surtout de faire qu'on travaille en
synergie entre de multiples services
puisque la difficulté
justement de trouver des solutions pour
les élèves en situation de décrochage
scolaire dont qui ont des parcours en
amour atypique c'est de trouver la bonne
porte d'entrée
les ateliers vont donc se poursuivre ici
toute la journée pour rappel les
propositions qui ressortiront de ces
différents groupes de paroles seront
utilisés pour l'élaboration d'un plan
d'actions pluriannuel contre le
décrochage scolaire
pas toujours facile pour les parents
d'allier activités des enfants et
travaille face à l'impossibilité de se
dédoubler une manie quazal ans et qui
drive ou une plateforme en ligne
d'entr'aide entre parents pour réaliser
les trajets estrac scolaires à des
enfants les explications dans ce
reportage avec lucas houdart une
plateforme pour mutualiser les trajets
des activités extra scolaires des
enfants le principe de qui drive ou
mettre en lien des parents à proximité
la plateforme geo callies les parents
qui sont proches de chez vous pour
pouvoir covoiturer qu accompagner en
fonction du monde de transport souhaité
des horaires des joueurs etc qui sont
renseignés dans la plateforme du coup
entre parents
l'application est parti d'un besoin
ressenti par la fondatrice mme annick
oise mère de deux enfants chacun
participé à une activité différente en
même temps il s'avère que je pouvais pas
qu'on va faire qu'on voiture et mes deux
enfants à 15 minutes d'intervalle et à 5
kilomètres de différence du coup j'ai eu
cette idée de pouvoir accompagner entre
parents de confiance c'était vraiment
important pour moi pour gérer mes
enfants maman d'une famille recomposée
difficile pour vinci and de gérer les
activités de chacun une fois par semaine
depuis le mois de septembre une qui
drivait emmène son fils à son cours de
dessin un trajet en moins pour la maman
le fait de ne pas avoir à saisir on va
voir mardi il faut que je parte plutôt
parce qu'il a des seins ou alors ah bah
non là j'ai une réunion c'est galère
voilà je peux pas y aller machin non je
sais que j'ai toujours quelqu'un qui va
y aller moi ça me permet d'avoir une
amplitude plus large pour mes horaires
de travail ce jour là donc c'est enfin
c'est clairement en terme de logistique
dans la tête d'une maman qui peut être
très très très lourde cc voilà c'est
très très confortable qui drive ou est
lancée depuis juin 2021 le service
pourrait s'élargir prochainement pour
inclure les trajets d'école
et avant de refermer ce journal l'espace
rambouillet fermera ses portes ce samedi
27 novembre à 17 heures pour la saison
hivernale mais ne rouvrira pas au
printemps dans quelques mois le parc
animalier passera en gestion privée un
appel à projets a été lancé par lohan f
qui gère actuellement le site trois
opérateurs ont été retenus et devront
présenter un projet d'ici décembre en
respectant un cahier des charges précis
le futur gestionnaire devrait être connu
à l'été 2022 et décidera de la date de
réouverture du parc et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis dans un instant retrouver votre
nouvelle émission présentée par grigori
à canal et l'émission consacrée aux jeux
olympiques 2000 24 dans les yvelines
merci à tous et très bonne soirée sur tv
[Musique]